[Musik]
das schlagzeug als soloinstrument die
hören vier fahrer hier 1971 am
jazzfestival zürich begonnen aber hatte
der vielseitige schweizer perkussive
ganz anders
[Musik]
das ist eine ganz vielfältig
hören wir zurück zusammen mit der
pianistin ihren schweizer wird farbe zur
leitfigur des europäischen free jazz
[Musik]
jeder nacht um 3 uhr bin ich am
schlagzeug
[Musik]
weil da habe ich die ganze zeit der
unendlichkeit und eine stunde immer
voller energie fließt ganz im körper und
so ich spiel' ich gesund
[Musik]
pierre fabre blickt auf eine karriere
als tanzmusiker bigband angestellte
radio und fernseh musiker wie bob
sideman und free jazz pionier zurück
immer wieder durchbricht der barrieren
um sich neu zu erfinden
bis er schließlich seine königsdisziplin
findet das solo schlagzeug
[Musik]
yeah
65 jahren diese daten unterwegs
wenn ich das gezeigte nicht mehr habe
das wird es mir das unterwegssein weil
es schick mir sehr viel leben und man
gewöhnt sich daran immer weiter zu gehen
das ist in der musik dasselbe und ich
schaue immer nach vorne und freue mich
auf das tor des kommt ebenfalls neues
mai
[Musik]
eine menge meiner
eine entdeckung
bestellungen
[Musik]
geboren wurde ich total la brevine im
grunde
der europäische weil es so im winter aus
schrecklich kalt
sollte ich warten
sie hat in diex andere city
aber als ich 15 jahre alt war kam ein
bruder
mehr
die schwarze bebel mitglieder
er hatte eine kleine ich habe zuerst in
absolut gast nicht gefallen aber er sagt
seit tagen laufen wie ein fall du musst
das spielen und die leute bis zum tanzen
hab ich gemacht
und im moment kann ich nicht mehr vom
fleck weg
mit 17 war ich ehrlich berufen
die leute konnten kaum leben wissen
gestorben das war wirklich zu halten
es waren auch zur jagd sind da waren in
italien
da der akribie juden zu genutzter
flächen alles leute die man hier in
honigwaben folglich
es hat keine spezielle militär
ausgebracht dazu machen wie man es mein
keine anpassung
kopf gerade
übrigens die kommission einen
geburtsfehler
ich zeige
das kleine haus
da bin ich gebunden
continental sowie der national
basketball gibt richtig
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hier ist mein vater immer gewisse
wortlos die einfach alles betrachtet ich
dachte immer es en alte indianer
es ist immer noch bewohnt von 100 spürt
man
er war mein erster lehrer hat mir
erzählen dass man als gast blieb sein
team den 1
eine kuh ist auch sie noch an gelooss
und er hat gewartet dass sie trat in die
höhe war es ihr auf den kopf gesprungen
als sich an die zwei hörner gehalten und
die coole seite geräumt habe hoch und
nur der müde dachte er weg bringen
einfach von den kindern ist unglaublich
für probiere ich zu spielen
[Musik]
aber
für dich
die ok
[Musik]
das waren konnte die spd auf wieder
lernen
aber meine liebe war meint janßen
möglicherweise daneben habe ich mich
das spiel
großmann kannst du auch alle großen
namen konnte ich begleitet
statt mir die garitzer erträglich
gemacht
in basel bestimmt die amateurmusiker die
letzten ausschreitungen
[Musik]
es liegt der st
ich verstehe warum man hat gesagt so ein
sieg kann gar nicht doch york spielen er
sieht nicht so aus
ich musste nachher spielen das ist
interessant war in ordentliche junior
gedichten
er war autoverkäufer sehr erfolgreich in
allem was er machte war erfolgreich und
er hat später gewagte musik zu machen
[Musik]
bei
und zwar genauso wie und recht oft sind
wir am freitag gaben nach der arbeit in
ihren wagen gestiegen nach paris
gefahren und er autobahn aber um
rechtzeitig zu kommen für noch ein oder
zwei setting jazzclub am sonntagabend im
letzten letzte mögliche moment schnell
den wahren boom nach basel über die
nacht und um 9 uhr wieder zu erscheinen
an unser unsere respektive jobs das
radio psr warten hast du dann verlassen
waren gute taten job warum ich finde
ich war ein
ich zeige dich
goldmann sagte unsicher
risiko ist viel billiger
darin kommt es neben das überleben
im leben habe ich mir mal das risiko
gewählt und nicht die sicherheit das
sagt mir erlaubt nicht weiter zu wecken
und es hat sicher sie sind es war mehr
sicherheit in dieser risiko als ein paar
zu bleiben und stärke in ruhe sterben
was machste reich geworden so ihnen in
lockerer art werden außerdem dass diese
auch gestern wurden alle gekündigt
später und ich war schon auf eur im flug
zum leben nimmt
in den 60er jahren habe ich dann
regelmäßig in paris gespielt
warum gründer von zwei dort auch wegen
existenzialismus sagt pantzer weg und
zurück
kultur als class ort erbrachte berühmt
dort habe ich leute gleich mit
denke es war einmal
dann habe ich auch jetzt sehr gut
[Musik]
analyse
das hat sich ihr gewicht nicht geändert
geboren
hier habe liege wohl liegen rücken in
die fünfziger partie ständig auf der
treppe getroffen um gespielt haben sie
etwas weiter es war hier draußen eine
straße weiter tabu gespielt
sie haben nicht reguliert aber sie haben
immer besser
[Musik]
am 1
das gleiche angebot
vorne rechts oder gleich nicht abwickeln
straßencafés der 75
euro
[Musik]
für apollo
das war das verbot der pid aus
mit
[Musik]
es ist einfach in einem luxus hotels
nichts mehr außer zwei fotos die da
hängen mit ihren welche leute die da
hinten etwas deutlicher aber der ganze
atmosphäre ganze es war im keller nicht
mehr im keller des ist alles vorbei
alles vergessen der kommt meiner fiel
ein ort wo die vergangenheit total
[Musik]
ola
das war 1960 und so hat dass da durchaus
gesehen das war ein fehler
sie gehört man habe auch darauf zurück
dass viele leute nicht mehr kommen nicht
jeder für sich
es war fair sexualisiert und die musik
war einst damit liegt
[Musik]
ich habe mein leben lang gekämpft
er werde große finanzielle probleme viel
arbeit ich hatte sehr viel fall
natürlich schön war das alles aber
bequem war es nicht
ich bin manchmal nicht den nächten lang
gefahren
tausende kilometer einfach gefangen auch
im schnee am rande erschöpfung oder
gearbeitet so sie gearbeitet
also ich habe glück gehabt es stimmt
aber die freiheit
das hat den großen teil
[Musik]
da reicht
das war die ruine
das glückte als folge der weinanbau
hüfte an hüfte geben nicht gesprochen
dazu gehört das wahre größe genick lag
der meister des modernen schlagzeug er
hat nichts mehr bei den spielen gedacht
gefreut nicht laut
[Musik]
ballaballa
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
meistens gespielt da begann
kabel an bord von rund
dann bin ich der familie gefahren wir
sind angekommen ist das ist wir hatten
kein geld
die beklagte bestellt
die war nicht ja und dann haben wir ein
zimmer in ein hotel errichtet im bahnhof
bekommen wie zwei kleine kinder
dazwischen problematisch wenn die kinder
über ihre geschäftsstelle gestört
saisonsieg gekommen das war verdammt ist
das wort wenn nicht war
euro
[Musik]
aber danach zwei monate später leblos
der richtige musik
erwarten haben
wieder haben
für alle zu regeln
[Musik]
wie alles kommt mal zu ende aber gott
sei dank hat ist und was räder hat
die pens und großes orchester in
deutschland angebot bekommen
dort hinauf wieder mit familie gefahren
dass dieses orchester
[Musik]
julian von david ich war gerade hinter
ihm
ich spüre er hat sowie emma das
orchester in der angenommen gefühlt
der kraftfahrer und alle haben gut
gespielt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
max reger orchester haben gelernt aber
ich wollte einfach
essemtec
und überraschenderweise bekam ich ein
angebot aus der schweiz und 1966 zu
weisen
[Musik]
das gute soll kommen das böse soll gehen
diese chinesische schriftzeichen auf
einem der weltgrössten gongs sind symbol
für die weltweiten beziehungen eines
kleinen betriebes am sempachersee was
selbst die einwohner der gemeinde
nottwil kaum wissen ist aber sowohl den
beatles wie den wiener philharmonikern
bekannt hier werden symbols hergestellt
schien allen die nach dem urteil der
musiker zum besten gehören was auf dem
markt erhältlich ist der wand hängt noch
von hand bezeichnet
[Musik]
recht
trainer thomas leek wie die linie dass
wir das vorstelle so toll geklappt aber
in guter typ
ein toller typ und die ich war verwirrt
die lachen alle und ich frage mich und
sie lachen wenn das hin dass die stadt
zug stehen weil sie lachen er fahrt der
schweizer spitzen schlagzeuger gehört
ebenfalls zum betrieb er prüft jeden
einzelnen cymbal bevor er die fabrik
verlässt dann eben für die beziehungen
zu jazz musikern aller welt und
interessiert sich für die wünsche der
schlagzeuger und verfolgt die
entwicklung des modernen jazz
[Musik]
ein bisschen entspannter mit dem
mittagessen
[Musik]
interessant ist bei den groß wie sie
gemacht werden
man sucht eine platte die gutes
potenzial hat dann zieht man an zu
kümmern
bis dort und dann liegen lassen
[Musik]
das sieht man das wieder und hat wieder
biss nicht verpassen ist da und dann
liegt es wieder dann kommt wieder dieser
arbeit
es gibt für uns das lernen nicht etwa
üben üben üben sondern aufnehmen
erfahren und nacharbeiten lassen
das braucht man man kann nicht einfach
endlos ebenso darin man will man sieht
man wir den robot aber geschichten die
sich zusammenfinden
das gibt die echte rechte decken habe
auch das gefühl für instrumente
zu der zeit als sicher
beste war hat sich bei mir da etwas
ich habe viele afrikanische musik gehört
es hat mich sehr inspiriert auch bei
indische musik koreanische musik
koreanische blues das ist extrem stark
und so verschiedene musikarten das hören
von alle diese fantastische musik es hat
nicht so getragen
in eine art trance wie der jazz ihn in
den westen moment das ich habe
herausgefunden es gegner solo ins all
wenn ich wirklich frei dichten und
nirgendwo wenn ich so frei wieder
[Musik]
mit
[Applaus]
ich habe sehr viel gemacht
viele zeit dabei ist er selbst
wir werden sicherlich gemacht
lebensjahr
nächtelang gelaufen
vier jahren habe ich bis jetzt überlegt
ich habe freunde die nicht überleben
aber wie ich gemerkt habe alles was man
erlebt hat was macht das was man heute
spielen
man sieht sind leute sagen seit 50
jahren machte das gleiche
jemand sagte das gleiche behandeln
aber es gibt auch viele sagen soll und
solo piazolo soll ob sie habe keine
ahnung was ich entwicklerkits hatte
setzte ich nicht dass ich nicht wechseln
ich ändern oder das nicht wir nicht
anerkennen weiß nie aber für mich nur
mehr mental wie ich jetzt bin ich hole
so viel neues aus dem alten das ist mir
reicht
was ich bei ihm schon gemerkt habe er
hat manchmal die gleichen witze gemacht
aber mit so eine kindlichkeit so einen
enthusiasmus das ist jedes mal ganz neu
war die devise nicht das ist auch das
ist auch wichtig dass man das was man so
über schwimmen freude machen
[Musik]
es hat mich eingeladen heute abend mit
ihm ein konzert zum probieren
ich lasse mich überraschen das ist für
mich wieder etwas neues
[Musik]
seine künste als im soll er macht seit
20 jahren so sache
[Musik]
und die artnet teams bietet die auch uns
maschine
[Musik]
in alabama
der 1
aragon ag
dpa
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du bist auch ein kinder nicht alle
[Gelächter]
die leute sagen du schwimmst weil deine
backenzähne wollte dich mit elf pleiten
in einer bern stecken musste abgesagt
und dann kam die korea und gesagt die
helfer mitgemacht hast auch abgesagt kam
zu mir erklärt warum du das gemacht hat
ja also ich habe die musik von der kraft
und sehr gerne gehabt aber es hätte
zwischen uns nicht gegeben nichts
wertvolles und mit südkorea war so
begeistert dass ich ja schön aber ich
habe das nicht entschieden sein instinkt
hat gesagt nein es war richtig warum
warum weil nach vegas gegangen wäre eine
anschlagsserie schlagzeuger mehr
geworden und alles was ich hier gemacht
habe was ich noch machen ich bin noch
nicht fertig wären nicht möglich wäre
[Musik]
dass hier das fahrzeug das ist da wo
meine welt ist das ist meine kraft
als ich zehn war ich hätte eine
herzkrankheit und der spezialist in dem
wir tief große hoffnung hatten hatten
zwar die klare dieses kind wird nicht
über 20 lebt
und wenn er überhaupt in der leeren
macht höchstens als büro und ja nicht
mit treppe sondern nur mit fahrstuhl
ich bin jetzt 80
der tod macht wird gerne aus mehr
ich hatte meine nächtliche spielen
unsere nachdenken dürfte froidevaux mit
dem tod das ist nicht kalt es ist nicht
[Musik]
der tag ist etwas wie wäre es mit ali
aus dem kokon aus fliegt glauben
[Musik]